[Applause]
foreign
symbolic place called zorbet the
minister of Education was the target
with the uh the twin bombings
um really a you know a busy time a
heavily used intersection but again you
know al-shabab is using all its tactics
to scare and make somalis in the capital
some of the areas are soft targets just
because
um it's used by the public it is they're
located in in large areas that are
um you know part of the city central so
it's really hard to sometimes prevent
these attacks but nevertheless I think
we have seen a reduction in in the facts
it just tells you that shabab is being
rooted out but they are really a force
to be reckoned with and it will take
time for Shabbat to be eliminated from
the capital but the work is ongoing now
we'll see more attacks I am sure just
because of the ongoing government and
and Community Uprising that we are
seeing across the country